guys let's just say you win in december
hypothetically you win fight is over in
your mind you're going to win the fight
so that's over with okay so now dustin's
the guy you're everywhere right i'm
talking every freak there's everybody
has to come through you you call the
shots
if he wanted to
and you guys fought in 2022 how
confident are you if you went up against
khabib i'm very confident i can beat
anybody in the world
anybody in the world
but at the same time i'm honest with
myself and i understand this is combat
sports and and i can lose to anyone as
well but my skill set i believe 100 of
my skill set and work ethic i can beat
anyone
it's exciting to be in that state and
you know what makes you unique is your
level of humility so
in in uh uh uh in the what's been
happening a lot lately is with jake uh
paul tyrone woodley i don't know if you
saw the fight oh you were was that the
player you were out the fight i saw you
were everywhere yeah what do you think
about the fight jake against tyrone i
thought tyron was gonna do a lot a lot
better than that you know he's been in
the gym
for the last 15 years fighting training
mixed martial arts he's a former world
champion
but he's not about he's a big puncher
but he's not a boxer the art of boxing
is is different
it's um it's a different thing
you think if you like let's i'm not
saying it's gonna happen i'm just saying
if you did fight these guys as a boxer
is there any chance they can go up
against you if they box you i think i
beat all these guys in boxing every one
of these guys yeah these these um social
media guys crossing over yeah yeah i
punish them
confidently it's not even like a thought
i'm not being cocky but i know you're
not being this is how i feed my family
and i've grown up in the gyms and become
a man in these gyms um under the
pressure and fire of fighting so when i
speak about fighting i speak about it
strongly because i care about this stuff
no it's by the way just so you know it's
felt your fire is felt that's not you
can't act that way it's very natural so
max
max uh uh you know historically is known
as being one of the better boxers in uh
in the mma and you went up against him
twice and you won both times and the
second fight you guys had sick fight i
mean we should have paid 300 to watch
that fight was that sick of a fight what
is it like fighting max max is a guy who
um
his
pace is hard to keep up with fortunately
for me i i work hard and build my
aerobic capacity and
and my cardio
and muscle endurance but i have a
natural gift i'm thankful for it but i i
can be out of shape off the couch and go
to the gym and outlast a lot of these
guys physically
i don't know how why it's just the way
my body's wired so i'm thankful for that
so i was able to keep up with his pace
and make him make mistakes you know he
was the current world champion at the
time he moved up in weight and i beat
him
but
in there i felt his understanding of
combat sports and and i felt his
knowledge and his skill set he's an
incredible fighter
if you were to put of all the people you
fought i'm a dog fight type of person
who would you put at the top not best
puncher not ground i'm talking dogfight
like this guy's not gonna stop he's
relentless who would you put at the top
that i've faced yeah max has to be at
the top you know i've hit him which i
hit him with so many shots he was hurt
multiple times
um another one at the at that on that
list is justin gaichy
i mean the guy's a wrecking ball he he
walks forward with reckless abandonment
for his own body and his own health to
to land his shots
but that's why he's such a fun fighter
to watch very cool do you think connor's
going to make a comeback
that injury man you know he broke the
tibia amphibia that's gonna be a long
road but
look at all the things the guy's
accomplished if anybody can come back
from that it's him you know i wish him i
don't hate any of these guys it's very
obvious um all the stuff said and and
the
you know
he he could he could you know he's a
former multi multiple time world
champion and he knows how to work he has
money he has a team around him so if he
wants to build it back up he has all the
the things to do that how do you stay
motivated when you're getting paid as
much as he's getting paid
i don't know man did i say it's hard to
wake up and run those miles and when you
sleep in the soap pajamas
[Laughter]
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]